We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David P got a very weird voicemail.
Here's my question.
Is this an anti-Trump voicemail or is this
a voicemail against those who are anti-Trump?
In other words, is this person on the left
or on the right?
Is this person angry with me or are they angry
with Trumpists?
Let's see if we can figure it out through
all of the expletives.
I uh, mr pack man.
What is up with all the hate mongering on
your Facebook threads there?
This is a dickless.
How can you say this and not want to go say,
Hey, y'all came in bait.
I bet it's ridiculous.
What the fuck is wrong with you people?
You want to make fun of people I liked their
hateful just cause they won't see care boaters
and then look, it's yo yo or is hateful, ignorant
as campaign.
Please ain't see your phone.
So I can tell you how far you are.
Wait, getting to Bay.
I will be respectful and see your phone.
What is it you only, uh, answer when it's
from an area code is Democrat majority.
No.
Well, don't go you lazy and only answer it
two or three times a day
a week.
You don't do nothing but hate monger and lie
on Facebook and it's pathetic.
The answer your phone so we can talk and cut.
Uh, we can come to a conclusion on whether
or not your hate Margaret or not.
Yeah.
Okay.
So by the end it's very clear this person
is angry with me.
Uh, no, we, I don't sit around answering the
phone two to three times a day.
Uh, we, we take phone calls once, sometimes
twice a week and I would love it if you called
in to talk to me.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about a Harvard law professor
suing the New York times over that guy who
supposedly committed suicide.
But a lot of people are skeptical about that.
There's also a conservative mom's group that
is really mad at burger King for a particular
word in one of their ads, and voters in California
could decide whether California cities will
be punished for not reducing homelessness.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show, become a member instantly by signing
up@joinpacmandotcomorbybecomingapatronatpatrion.com
slash David Pakman photo.
I will speak you that the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com.